es ist eine einmalige chance der
menschheit zum ersten mal wird eine nova
jahre im voraus vorhergesagt demnach
wird sie 2022 am nachthimmel als
gigantische sternenexplosionen zu sehen
sagen vielen dank an den themenvorschlag
von luzie wären diese explosion wird sie
voraussichtlich die energie abgeben wie
unsere sonne während ihrer gesamten
existenz ab straße ein gigantisches
ereignis zwei sterne kollidiert und
explodieren in einer roten nova und wir
können diese explosion mit bloßem auge
sehen
sensationell wann und vor allem wo wird
das passieren
das thema jetzt endlich zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen so wird wie
aussehen eine rote nova in den tiefen
des weltraums von jetzt auf gleich
explodieren fall sterne und leuchten
10.000 mal heller als vorher dafür ist
der ausbruch von v8 38 monot erotisch
der am sechsten januar 2002 entdeckt
wurde
begonnen hatte er wahrscheinlich bereits
am ersten januar aber da hatte ihn
nämlich noch niemand entdeckt denn das
ist der haken bei solchen ereignissen im
riesigen weltall im vorhinein zu wissen
wo ein solcher ausbruch stattfindet so
möglich die chancen stehen eins zu einer
million
wie beim lotto doch jetzt scheint der
astronom lorenz müller von calvin
college in den usa einen solchen
einmaligen treffer gelandet zu haben er
hat nämlich beim doppel sperren knc 983
2227 eine erstaunliche beobachtung
gemacht diese beiden sterne scheinen
sich nämlich immer schneller zum greifen
genau das ist schon was 2008 passiert
damals explodierte der doppelstern v130
1 kopie auch ihr umkreisten sich zwei
doppelsterne immer schneller und
verschmolzen schließlich mit einem
rötlichen scheint genau das soll jetzt
auch passieren allerdings wird es drei
erhebliche unterschiede geben macht es
zu einer absoluten länder zur erstens
wissen wir wann es passieren wird und
zweitens wissen wir wo es passieren wird
und drittens was der absolute hammer ist
wir werden diese explosion mit bloßem
auge erkennen können das hat es noch nie
gegeben mollner und seine kolleginnen
und kollegen haben sich den doppelstern
in den letzten zwei jahren nochmal sehr
genau angesehen und tatsächlich steuert
alles auf die nova 2000
23 zu die begeisterung am college in
michigan ist riesig das wäre ein
bedeutendes ereignis nicht nur für die
wissenschaft sondern auch weil es die
menschen auf der straße faszinieren kann
so koautor matt ward wenn die vorhersage
stimmt dann wäre dies das erste mal in
der geschichte dass eltern auf eine
dunkle stelle am himmel zeigen können
und sagenweg kinder dort versteckt sich
ein stern der balkan hell aufleuchten
wird ja und dann würde auch tatsächlich
aufleuchten wahnsinn genau hier im
sternbild des schwans würde sein und in
den wochen und monaten vorher wird es
wahrscheinlich immer genau möglich sein
den exakten zeitpunkt vorherzusagen wenn
ihr bei der produktion deutsch
spannender videos dabei sein wollt und
bei pixum mitmachen wollt dann bewerbt
euch wir suchen zur zeit eine
praktikantin oder einen praktikanten für
den schnitt ich freue mich sehr auf eure
bewerbung an bewerbung at krachten punkt
net der link ist auch normal und mit der
video beschreibung und zur roten nova
ich kann euch jedenfalls versprechen
dass ich bis dahin ein eigenes teleskop
haben werde und es natürlich auch das
sternbild des schwans ausrichten werden
wenn es neue zu dem thema gibt dann
halten wir euch hier natürlich auf dem
laufenden wenn ihr kein video dazu und
zu den zahlreichen anderen themen hier
verpassen wollten durch mir hier ein abo
aufs auge und vergiss nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit erste
aufzeichnung einer supernovaexplosion da
konnte vor einem jahr durch die
helligkeit änderung einer ganzen galaxie
der ausbruch einer supernova verfolgt
werden das war schon eine absolute
sensation wenn es euch interessiert auf
jeden fall drauf klicken und wenn nicht
dann bleibt dran